welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Doctor Strange in the Iron Man
armor may be more than a hypothetical
concept art from the Infinity Saga but
actual shot footage
according to the nerd in chief Kevin
Smith imagery that is now looking even
more likely to appear in the upcoming
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness because they got to use
something to string together these
future Marvel movies while every movie
production is delayed from quarantine
8th hey thanks to modern editing
techniques we can use existing footage
to complete the film without COBIT
immune staff what you're fired actually
I think I would pay to watch that don't
worry dr. strange and the multiverse of
madness looks like it's going to back
Marvel's multiverse with all kinds of
madness including some nostalgic
fanservice to the daddy who loved us
3,000 ok when the Infinity Saga box set
came out we saw some interesting concept
art showing Tony Stark and dr. strange
switching wardrobes suggesting some
proposed but ultimately rejected concept
for the way is scenes that have gone but
then recently Kevin Smith revealed on
his fat man Beyond podcast which you
should definitely subscribe to if you
don't already that not only had they
seen this art before endgame was
released they saw footage of this
deleted scene from the screenwriters
Chris Marcus and Stephen McFeely now
this is the moment Doctor Strange was
being tortured by ebony maw on the cue
ship an attempt to get the time stone
from the ienaga moto and Tony Stark
spider-man and the cloak of levitation
schemes to save strange by sucking mah
out the airlock like the alien queen and
aliens but according to Smith the
alternate scene was going to go down
this way originally Tony was gonna send
the armor down to Doctor Strange in the
way he could in in Iron Man 3 and then
the armor covered him and turned him
into dr. mage and the instead of the you
know the arc reactor it built around the
eye of agamotto and then Tony was
wearing dr. strange cape and it brought
him down to him after
however they dispatched epidemis and by
the way we know Smith is telling the
truth about them shooting the scene
because there was behind-the-scenes
footage of Robert Downey jr. on set
wearing the cloak of levitation and
Kevin Smith went on to describe seeing
this footage in his holies colorful
language and they pulled out the phone
and literally showed us not just a
drawing because that's what's going
around the internet is there's a drawing
and [ __ ] looks badass and [ __ ] but they
showed us Sherlock in the Iron Man suit
man like wearing the goddamn suit with
tony standing next to him wearing the
cape and we were like what the that man
so Marvel comics have shown us versions
of Tony Stark as the sorcerer supreme
there was a what-if comic storyline back
in the day where he fights Dormammu with
his combined tech and magic as a
sorcerer supreme and then in the more
recent Marvel Legacy comics there's dr.
Anthony Stark from the future who
becomes so enlightened he becomes the
sorcerer supreme in the year 2099 and
there are super recent comics in which
Doctor Strange gets Iron Man type armor
in recent months Savage Avengers number
nine strange fights alongside Doctor
Doom and Conan the Barbarian against the
sorcerer kulan Gath strange gets bitten
by a magical snake and to save him from
death they activate a satellites to
admit an armored suit Iron Man armor
that doom previously wore during a brief
period when he replaced Iron Man but
with this new armor strange becomes the
iron mage
now this storyline was from January came
out after endgame obviously so it
wouldn't have influenced whatever the
filmmakers had in mind back years ago
for infinity war an endgame but back
then if they went so far as to shoot
this scene that Smith is describing
there must have been a good reason to
remove it from the film something beyond
what they ended up doing revealing the
iron spider Waldo's and panama's don't
want the greatest films of all time
both actually those are pretty good
reasons to change it but when it comes
to Iron Man's armor in these movies we
know that Marvel almost always considers
introducing new tech in earlier films
but it's upshifting that introduction
over to deleted scenes so that they can
refine the VFX for future releases like
Tony Stark's flashy new nanotech armor
and and benedi war was actually
introduced way back in Iron Man 2 you
know it means something
okay oh my nano ball I don't want to
play with your ball I'll play with it
this transferable nanotech was actually
what it would it looks like when Tony's
armor covered dr. strange in the
Infinity war deleted scene not so much
like the propulsion powered pieces of
the armor in Iron Man 3 but a fluid
swarm of nanobots similar to the motion
of fabric which would have made Tony in
the cloak and aesthetically even trade
the nanotech VFX obviously wasn't ready
to go back in Iron Man 2 and even an
infinity war while it looks great when
it bursts the symbols around Tony in New
York you gotta admit it looks a little
less great when he's fighting Thanos on
Titan and not just because the armors
weakened it just looks a little like
sure yet like Tony's Papa Howard Stark
Marvel Studios artists were limited by
the technology of their time yet still
shot the moon with their raw visions
with hopes that a future generation
could finally crack the magic in the
soon-to-be most visually stunning and
mind-blowing marvel installment Doctor
Strange goes down
big smog while I'm sorting through these
clues trying to figure out how the
movies will actually play out it helps
to study up on how movies are made one
way I do that is with Skillshare thanks
to Skillshare for sponsoring this video
springtime is near so let's do some
spring cleaning of our souls shake off
that winter dormancy and try something
new new skills deepen existing passions
or get lost in creativity with skill
shares online classes what you find just
might surprise and inspire you skill
share is an online learning community
that offers membership with meaning with
so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives Skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth Skillshare offers
classes designed for real life so you
can move your creative journey forward
without putting life on hold you can
learn and grow with short classes that
fit your busy routine they have classes
and topics new rock stars fans will
definitely enjoy like animation film
video creative writing the class i've
been checking out is their original
storytelling in film using
cinematography to convey emotion taught
by director of photography joe simon
Skillshare is also incredibly affordable
to join especially when compared to
those pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual Skillshare
subscription is less than 10 bucks a
month
the first 500 of my subscribers to click
the link in the description will get a 2
month free trial of premium membership
so that you can explore your creativity
we have posted all kinds of theories for
what doctor strains and the multiverse
of madness might look like it's a bit
hard to nail down especially what
director scott derrickson being replaced
by Sam Raimi and a new screenwriter
low-key showrunner Mike Waldron but
based on the footage for one division
marvels multiverse appears to be one
that bends genre presenting in various
what if alternate realities into me that
suggests perhaps an adaptation of
something like the Captain Britain Corps
leave Captain Britain Brian Braddock
himself getting a nearly miserable
shout-out in endgame the crisis being
suffered by Wanda Maximoff warps the
fabric of reality so that alternate
realities converge on each other much
like the dimensions of Spider Man into
the spider verse and then in multiverse
of madness Stephen strange encounters
alternate Avengers from other realities
like Captain Britain and maybe an
ultimate sorcerer supreme iron mage with
Benedict Cumberbatch also playing a
version of himself from another
dimension a place where the sorcerer
supreme uses stark nanotech armor
empowered with mystic energy and now
with years of ever brewing VFX
technology Marvel's artists will finally
have a stun
visual display of the iron major armor
that just looks glorious as it fends off
held demons from nightmare that snow
ever it is and my greatest hope is that
the engineer behind this iron mage armor
from another dimension will not be an
alternate Tony Stark but a science
wizard from that reality that we have
been dying to see an our reality Victor
Von Doom played by Keanu Reeves please
God no deeper theories about the future
of the MCU join our discord server by
becoming a patron today at patreon.com
slash new rock stars which MCU character
do you want to see in the Iron Man armor
comment down below follow me a da vas
followed new rock stars and subscribe to
new rock stars to breakdowns of
everything Marvel thanks for watching
bye
[Music]